the un
says that without fresh targets
uh on the or progress we've made until
now we certainly aren't going to limit
the rise in global surface temperature
to 1.5 in fact um they're talking this
week of a forecast of
2.7 degrees you're gonna need to get
some new measures out of the next two
weeks to hit the 1.5 target that you've
talked about well trevor this is
obviously a very big tough ass that
we've got here in glasgow but i think
it's worth reflecting on where we've got
to so before paris uh analysts suggested
that we were heading towards six degrees
of global warming after paris that uh
temperature code was bent downwards
under four degrees and actually if you
look at the uh un
report that you're referring to and of
course the international energy agency
report that suggests that if you take
all the commitments that have been made
by governments we have bent the curve
towards two degrees so there has been
progress the last few years but you know
i would say that actually the task we
have here is in many ways tougher than
paris paris was a a brilliant
achievement a historic achievement but
it was a framework agreement what we've
had to do since then is to agree some of
the detail rules and some of the most
difficult rules are still outstanding
after six years that makes it really
challenging and of course we know that
the geopolitics
is more difficult than it was at the
time of paris well let's come to some of
that but
you say that uh you know we've made
progress actually looking at what
countries have done
i think
we reckon that of the 35 most important
countries only the gambia has hit its
paris accord agreement
are you going to start by essentially
laying down the law to uh the the
parties here that basically they haven't
done what they said they would do in
paris well trevor you're right i mean
this is on world leaders at the end of
the day and uh they made the commitments
in paris that we would limit temperature
rises to well below degrees pursuing
efforts to 1.5 and now in glasgow they
have to deliver you know we've got the
g20 ongoing right now and those world
leaders will arrive here tomorrow for
the world leader summit and my message
them is very clear leave the ghosts of
the past behind you it is halloween
today after all but leave the ghost of
the past behind you and let's focus on
the future and unite around this one
issue that we know matters for all of us
which is protecting our precious planet
your colleague prime minister is not
very optimistic
um
he said to the u.n a month ago when
kermit the frog sang it's not easy being
green i want you to know he was wrong i
invite you in november to celebrate what
i hope will be a coming of age and to
blow out the candles of a world on fire
classic johnson boosterism this week he
said it's going to be very very tough
this summit and i'm very worried because
it might go wrong it's touch and go it's
very very difficult it's very far from
clear that we'll get the progress that
we need what happened in the weeks in
between those two statements well the
premise is absolutely right it is going
to be really really tough at this summit
we've got two weeks to get this over the
line but
he was also making the point that uh
when we took on the presidency of cop 26
less than 30 percent of the global
economy was covered by a net zero target
we're now at over 80 percent almost all
the g20 nations that we're talking about
have got a net zero target for the
middle of the century if i had come onto
this program a year ago trevor and i'd
said that to you you would have been
really skeptical so there has been
progress but there's much more but we're
talking promises here aren't we and
actually part of what you've got to do
in the next couple of weeks is arm
wrestle people into some new promises
now it's not that helpful that president
xi
uh president putin aren't turning up i
mean basically they're saying
honestly
we're not that bothered
well if you have a look at what uh both
president putin and president xi have
actually announced they both announced
uh net zero targets uh for the middle of
the century
one promises that haven't met
if i may and of course the world leader
summit is really important we've got
over 120 world leaders coming from you
know all over the globe but of course
what we're also going to have is two
weeks of detailed negotiations and those
teams are here i've met uh with some of
the representatives from russia from
china over the last few days i've been
doing the sort of pre-prep for crop for
cop itself and so that is what's going
to be really important is to get over
the line these key negotiation issues as
well and this is a chance quite frankly
for all of these countries to show
leadership this is the point where they
have to stand up and be counted do you
want more out of china
and russia than they have promised i
want more out of every country but i
think the point here is that we have
made progress and then we're going to
have to take stock of where there is a
gap in you know what the commitments are
and where we need to be and one of the
things we're going to have to discuss
and in a very consensus-led way is how
do we close that gap over this decisive
decade and you know some people are
suggesting we need to come back and look
at those commitments again those 20 30
commitments over the next couple of
years that is an agreement that's going
to come through consensus and it's my
job to help build that consensus what
are you going to do about the saudis and
the australians both of whom are
basically saying
fine we'll try and do what we can we'll
we'll plant some trees and so on but we
are absolutely not going to reduce
production of uh
oil in saudi's case and australia's case
before 2030 and that is going to stymie
your aim isn't it well both those
countries have committed to net zero by
the middle of the century and of course
the pressures on on them as it is on
every country to set out precisely how
they will do that and that's why we have
been asking for countries to set out
their long-term strategies for getting
to net zero the uk as you know in the
last few days has published its own uh
net zero strategy which has been
welcomed by very many is seen as a a
benchmark a global benchmark which
others can look at as well so you know
my ask is of every country come forward
with the detailed policies which will
deliver on the commitments that you've
made you mentioned the uk
the chancellor this week reduced airport
duty taxes he's made flying domestically
easier has he apologized yet for
undermining your credibility well
actually have you if you look at what
the chancellor has announced he's
announced very very many billions of
pounds of support uh to further our plan
for a green industrial revolution
let me address that that issue so
domestic aviation represents less than
one percent of our emissions in 2019 and
remember as a country over the last 30
years we've cut our emissions by over 40
percent and you need to see this
alongside the fact that we are investing
in sustainable aviation fuels we've got
a jet zero program
and of course there is an issue of
connectivity uh where because we are an
island uh you can't get that easily from
one part to the other which isn't the
case for every country are we going to
come out of here in two weeks with a
deal of some kind
that is what i'm driving towards and i
think what i've always said is that what
we need to come from out of glasgow is
to be able to say with credibility
that we have kept 1.5 alive and i know
you've got others on this program and
that 1.5 really matters we know from the
ipcc that we're already at global
warming of 1.1 degree above
pre-industrial levels at 1.5
there are countries in the world that
will be underwater and that's why we
need to get an agreement here on how we
tackle climate change over the next